la séance est
reprise l'ordre du jour appelle la
question orale de Monsieur Antoine
Lefèvre à monsieur le ministre de
l'éducation
nationale monsieur le Président Madame
la ministre mes chers collègues je
souhaite attirer votre attention sur les
conditions de recrutement des animateurs
supplémentaires auxquels les communes
doivent faire face dans le cadre de la
réforme des rythmes scolaires les
communes ayant opté pour une mise en
place des la rentrée 2013 ont dû non
seulement y consacrer beaucoup de temps
et d'énergie tant le délai était court
pour organiser les activités mais
doivent aussi faire face à la difficulté
de l'encadrement de ces dernières en
effet avec de nombreux ateliers proposés
aux enfants danse musique activités
sportives art plastique jeux théâtre et
cetera les mares sollicitent des
enseignants exerçant dans leurs écoles
du personnel communal mais aussi des
bénévoles ceci demande d'ailleurs de
façon aigu des précisions quant à savoir
sous quelle responsabilités sont placés
les enfants durant ces temps d'activité
périscola cependant ceci ne suffit
parfois pas et les communes doivent
faire appel à des intervenants
extérieurs soit pour deux soit pour 3
heures par semaine de plus et par souci
d'équité certains de ces idils
souhaiteraient que tous les intervenants
enseignants ou non enseignant
bénéficient de la même rémunération
alors que le décret numéro 66 787 du 14
octobre 66 permet de rémunérer à l'heure
des personnels enseignants du prer degré
qui acceptent d'effectuer des heures
supplémentaires pour le compte des
collectivités territoriales comme les
études surveillées et offre donc une
flexibilité appréciable il n est pas de
même pour les animateurs qui doivent
intervenir dans le cadre des ACT
activité périscolaire ces intervenants
extérieurs doivent être rémunérés selon
un cadre d'emploi bien défini et sur la
base d'une grille indiciaire agent non
titulaire de la fonction publique
nécessitant une création de postees sur
un temps préfixé avec déclaration de
vacances de poste à pourvoir auprès du
Centre de Gestion et une rémunération
sur la base d'un indice de la fonction
publique cela pose difficulté ces
intervenants ne travaillant pas durant
les vacances scolaires quel solution
alors adopt faut-il annualiser le temps
de travail ou alors établir des contrats
à durée déterminée et renouvelabl à
chaque vacance scolaire autre difficulté
concernant le cadre d'emploi la la
rémunération des assistants artistiques
danse et art plastique notamment musique
également est calculé sur la base d'une
durée hebdomadaire de 20h par semaine
alors que pour les éducateurs
d'activités physique et sportive c'est
sur la base d'une durée hebdomadaire de
35 he par semaine qui entraîne une
disparité de contrat d'un intervenant à
un autre or dans les classes DEAT dans
le cadre pardon des classes du
patrimoine organisé en partenariat avec
l'Éducation nationale il apparaît que
les intervenants peuvent être rémunérés
sur la base d'un taux horaire je vous
demande donc Madame la Ministre afin de
faciliter l'application de la réforme la
possibilité d'appliquer cette même
réglementation pour les intervenants en
tap je vous remercie merci mon cher
collègue la parole est à Madame George
Paul Levin ministre chargé de la réussé
éducative merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur Lefèvre je tiens
d'abord grâce à votre question à saluer
tous les élus qui se sont engagés
résolument dans la réforme des rythmes
éducatifs et qui effectivement je peux
en témoigner puisque je visite beaucoup
de communes euh mettent sur pied des
réalisations extrêmement intéressantes
dans ce cadre-là donc vous l'avez dit
les communes peuvent faire appel à une
grande diversité d'intervenants en
complément de leurs propres ressources
ce peut-être des associations
partenaires de l'école des mouvements
d'éducation populaire des associations
sportives ou culturelles locales et je
crois qu'effectivement j'en ai vu
beaucoup diverses et variés ces
intervenants doivent être des
personnalités qualifiées c'est-à-dire
euh répondre aux conditions posé par
l'arrêté du 9 février 2007 sur les
titres et diplômes permettant d'exercer
les fonctions d'animation ou de
direction en séjours de vacances du
moins ceux qui sont recrutés par les euh
municipalités les communes peuvent
également recruter des jeunes dans le
cadre d'un emploi d'avenir professeur et
à ce moment-là l'État prend en charge
les tris cas de la rémunération du jeune
concerné le décret de 19 novembre 1982
précise les conditions d'octroit
d'indemnité par les collectivités
territoriales et leurs établissements
publics aux agents des services
déconcentrés de l'État ou des
établissements publics de l'État sur la
base de ce texte les collectivités
territoriales peuvent allouer les
indamnités au personnel des services
déconcentrés de l'État dans le cadre
d'une activité accessoire qu'ils
exercent pour le compte de la
collectivité alors comme vous l'avez dit
effectivement des personnels enseignants
peuvent être concernés pour des services
d'étude surveillé ou de surveillance
conformément au texte d'application de
ce décret les services sont rétribués
par les collectivités territoriales au
moyen d'indamnité don les taux horaires
ne peuvent excéder se fixer par le
décret du 14 octobre 66 fixant le taux
de rémunération de certains travaux
supplémentair effectués par les
professeurs des écoles en dehors de leur
service normal on peut aussi faire appel
a des agents territoriaux qui exercent
déjà dans la collectivité en qualité de
titulaire ou de stagiaire et alors il
s'agit de de modifier le temps de
travail qu'ils exercent le temps de
travail peut-être annualisé vous avez
évoqué cette possibilité sauf pour les
professeurs et les enseignants les
assistants d'enseignement artistique
pour lesquels l'annualisation n'est pas
réglementaire enfin on peut aussi
recourir à des agents vacata le temps de
travail des assistants d'enseignement
artistique est fixé par leur statut et
dérange de ce fait autant de travail de
droit commun de la fonction publique
enfin rappelons que les collectivités
territoriales ne sont pas seules pour
mettre en œuvre ces activités
périscolaires puisque elles peuvent
l'organiser dans le cadre d'un pdt au
quel cas effectivement elles sont aidées
dans la mise en place par les le daen de
l'éducation nationale je dois dire que
il y a toutes sortes de ressources qui
peuvent être mobilisé dans le cadre de
la commune et il est vrai qu'en faisant
appel à des associations locales je
crois ou à des associations de grandes
associations complémentaires de
l'éducation publique la tâche des
communes peut se trouver sensiblement
alléger merci madame le ministre
monsieur le fure
oui merci madame la ministre de ces
éléments de de précision j'aurais aimé
quand même que vous me répondiez sur la
le problème de la responsabilité puisque
vous faites état justement de la
possibilité de faire appel de recourir à
des associations on voit de plus en plus
dans le cadre de ces nouveaux rythmes
scolaires des des des mairres qui fontou
des présidents de syndicats scolaires
qui font appel à des bénévoles il y a
quand même un vrai problème de
responsabilité qui interpelle
directement les les élus locaux il
faudrait quand même que le cadre soit
soit bien défini et puis je je note avec
satisfaction la possibilité donc
d'annualiser le temps de travail ça
permettra aussi un peu de plus de
facilité
merci merci mon cher collègue